[Music]
welcome to trigonometry I'm Francis
Foster I'm Constance and kissing and
this is the show for you if you're bored
of people arguing on the internet over
subjects they know nothing about
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we asked the experts our
fantastic expert guest this week is a
returning guest to trigonometry the
first returning guest to trigonometry
she's a former advisor to US president
and the founder of H robotics dr. Pippa
Malan grand I got it right yeah yes and
our amazing expert guest this week is
the columnist for The Spectator vice
chairman of the arguably advertising
group and one of the most amazing
creative counterintuitive thinkers in
the world today Rory Sutherland welcome
to trigonometry it's a joy to be here
our fantastic expert guest this week is
a psychologist and author dr. Linda
Papadopoulos welcome to trigonometry
thank you for having me let's just get
straight into first of all one of the
things you know this is called
trigonometry and we briefly mentioned
that I was telling you the study that I
saw that telling giving people trigger
warnings actually Prime's them to be to
have a negative experience of whatever
it is and you were like yeah please
please to ask me about that on the show
so what do you want to say to us as a
psychologist about that if you think of
one of the things that we're doing
called me to therapy right when someone
comes in and says look this is happening
to mean it's really bothering me one of
the things that we do is we look at
erroneous thinking so if I've come in
and I've said you know uh you know I
don't like stripes it may be that you
hear well Linda doesn't like me and you
know or she's being offensive and she's
being directly offensive now if you were
having therapy to be like well maybe
it's just that Linda had a bad
experience with stripes maybe it's
nothing personal maybe before you kind
of personalize this and become triggered
by it maybe you need to check out with
Linda why she said that so in a lot of
ways these these trigger warnings lot of
ways kind of priming people to be
offended is the exact opposite of what
we do in CBT which is take a step back
and reevaluate that thought right if I'm
going
my way to find something to be offended
about then I will be and there's a value
in being offended because if I'm
offended I can put myself in the role of
someone who's a victim then they need to
take care of me I can get sort of some
sort of I can get social points because
I've called you out for being whatever
being I'm thoughtful I'm caring so
there's a reason why this happens and I
think one of the things that that I
think we see a lot of these days with
regards to to people feeling that
vulnerability is precisely because I
think a lot of young people grew up in a
culture where their parents got rid of
obstacles they were like snow plows so
that a problem with the teacher they
went they spoke to a teacher on their
behalf they you know they didn't like
not being invited to kids party they'd
complain and they'd speak to the mother
and they convened provided to the party
a big part of dealing with life is
having the resilience to come back and
realize it's sometimes [ __ ] happens not
because someone's out to get me but
because things happen and I have to find
the strength to overcome these things so
I just kind of feel that a lot of the
way that we're talking about trigger
warnings and language being dangerous
basically D skills people from being
able to cope with these things and I
certainly wouldn't want that you know
for her my child or any of the young
people that I work with and you think
this behavior is addictive that once you
start and you cast yourself in the role
of victim you get this attention you
think just have hang on I quite enjoy
this whether consciously or
subconsciously well there's I think
there's a power in in being being seen
and being heard and look I think there
are some genuine people that are
victimized out there I think it's
important that we say that and I think
they should be able to speak up and talk
about it but I think intense importance
right if I bump into you I didn't mean
to bump into you then surely that
matters right now
the amount you hurt you know if you
really heard that that yeah that matters
to but the intent has to come into it my
kind of fear that it's very rarely about
intent
it's very really that I didn't notice
you had this Drive shirt on before I
said I don't like stripes I always
enjoy when your fashion sense gets
destroyed always the best I did show
this to my girlfriend yesterday and she
just looked at it and then walked out
the room you know when you're trying to
pet a cat and it's night you know so
there we go
Laurel those stories listen to you go
and listen to a disapproval um do you
think social media has made this worse
the fact that you know we're all
constantly logged in or looking for
approval we're all looking for likes etc
etc etc I I think it's um it's a huge
part of it I think yes they're looking
for approval and likes but I think also
kind of the distillation of one's
ideology down to their you know most
thoughtless tweet right so yeah if you
know surely we're an amalgam of all of
you know the ways that we interact our
interactions are opinions everything
else what because I can look into your
background and come up with the one time
that you used you know whatever you know
a word in the wrong way or you I really
liked something you didn't think about
and you retweeted it I think these
things mean that we are walking on
eggshells were constantly so anxious of
being misunderstood because they're like
we said earlier there's there's
something in calling out people for
being wrong so we've got this very weird
situation where we want to be seen so
we're constantly kind of saying this is
what I feel about this and I have an
opinion about that but at the same time
the rest of us are kind of looking to
call each other out because there's a
value in that as well so they like the
kind of the discourse isn't the
healthiest we're not kind of talking to
get to a better place of understanding
we're talking to kind of call each other
out and see well you hold on maybe you
didn't see that in the right way and
then that you know then those kind of
Twitter were starting yeah and do you
think it's it increases people's
narcissism using the social media yeah I
think it's inevitable that something
that the the that makes you think about
how you're seen in such a nuanced way
increases narcissism and and and I don't
mean that I mean it's actually really
kind of heartbreaking so I've got a
psychologist for many many years and
certain things that I see a lot of the
way they're depicted to me of change I
do a lot with eating disorders
and you know for for many years that the
big thing was a number right so I want
to be this wait I want to be this size
and then more recently people are
bringing in sort of pictures from
Instagram lists of hashtags like bikini
bridge or thigh gap or box gap which
means we're kind of standing outside
ourselves and looking in we're kind of
you know itself objectifying now this
self objectification while there's a
narcissistic element there's also an
element that kind of belies incredibly
dangerous low self-esteem because you
know not only am I looking myself
through my eyes but through the eyes of
you know everyone else that I feel is
looking at me and through their values
and through the way that they're gonna
assess me so yeah I always say if I was
going to create a an exercise for poor
self-esteem I tell people to take a
bunch of pictures of themselves look
through the ones that are like the least
awful then find that one and then spend
you know 20 minutes filter and get
thinking of a great hashtag then put it
up on social media then sit back and
wait for the likes and if 50 don't come
in the first 20 minutes take it down and
start over again that is literally an
exercise and you know on poor
self-esteem yet you know so many people
do it day in day out and and this idea
of not being able to live up to your
selfie
you know this discrepancy between who I
am and who I'm projecting I think is
having a significant effect on mental
health because there's there's no
ability to rest from from what does
everybody else think about me that's
constantly there there's no Billy just
say well this is who I am and maybe this
can be okay and I've always thought as
well that the kind of part of your job
as a human being as you mature is to
start to get to a point where your
self-esteem is driven by what you think
about yourself like a kind of sense of
who you are and it seems like social
media is taking that away from us and
kind of almost exploring our
vulnerabilities as human beings would
you say that we're particularly
vulnerable to social media as humans
well this is either such an interesting
point so again if you look at sort of
human evolution we've not evolved to
kind of absorb the opinions of thousands
and thousands of people ourselves right
we tend to live in sort of in groups and
and there's some research that attest
the fact that even the amount of friends
that we have should be no more than
about a hundred we just can't handle
or that's how we've evolved it works
well so social media is all about the
numbers like you say and so you know
being able to assimilate this kind of I
mean there's like bathroom doors anyone
can write whatever it is on the back but
because they're not in a little cubicle
with a smelly toilet they're there for
everyone to see it matters whatever's
written matters and if thousands and
thousands of people's opinions in the
diversity of the matter again that
that's a recipe for disaster because not
only do you not rest from it but you're
never like you say able to say do you
know what this is who I am this is the
imperfect version of Who I am in a while
I think we all want to you know self
actualize and reach our potential you
know part of that is saying I'll never
play in the NBA if I'm a certain height
or I'll never have a singing career if I
can stand out or whatever it is and and
being okay with that and I think that's
that's harder when you know those goal
posts are always you know sort of
changing but who you ought to be and
everyone's telling you well you're not
there yet
what do you think about what do you
think makes social media is so addictive
what is it specifically they designed it
that way why do we go into it so much I
even I do it even I do it the first
thing I do when I wake up in the morning
is check Instagram yeah because okay
this is very interesting again so up
until relatively recently psychology has
been used to help people right so you
have a problem you go to psychologists
you help them in the last sort of twenty
thirty years
psychology is slowly being used to to
persuade people there's there's places
called sort of persuasive technology
labs usually where you know places where
tech exists right so like Silicon Valley
where our psychology is being used
against us so for example I don't know
um you guys obviously Netflix right I
love Netflix
I can't watch one show anymore I rarely
fun watching a series I can rarely turn
off and watch them now the reason for
that is they know that if they start the
next one right away like they do I'm
more likely to stay they take away a
barrier if I can skip the intro I'm more
like Newsday they take away another
barrier because the metric for the
success of social media sites is times
online so they insure and not because
they're able I don't think any one of
these social media companies is bad or
evil they're just trying to to maximize
their profit maximize how successful
they are so if time spent online is what
they want when I'm devising whatever
Instagram snapchat Facebook I'm going to
ensure what will make you more likely to
say well I know that notifications well
why do you know um there's something
called variable reward system you know
like slot machines yeah you know why
they're addictive if every time you
pulled it
you know something would come out
there'd be not much to it you'd get it
when you wanted it but the fact that
sometimes it comes out every three times
you pull it sometimes it comes out every
five times means you're much more likely
to go back we know that that's very
basic human behavior now that variable
rewards system exists on all social
media sites it exists and when you see
that little notification at the bottom
it exists when you're gonna get some
sort of validation when you get that you
know the retweet it exists when someone
likes something we know that now also
there's gender differences here right so
if we look at the way that boys and
girls react differently we know that
boys tend to be much more apt to gaming
addiction why is that because we're
evolutionary perspective men are have
evolved to seek out competency
especially during those teen years young
boys now what does that mean that means
I want to feel like I'm getting good at
something now what better thing than if
I give you a game that I kind of think
ding ding give you a reward every little
while every delinquent so I feel better
and I get that dopamine rush and I play
more so I get more of a dopamine rush so
that becomes quite addictive for girls
we're taught to seek out kind of that
social equity right do you like me am I
you know I'm gonna have that equity do
you enjoy you know being with me and as
a consequence again those hearts those
likes are going to be very validating
and rewarding so you know behind your
phone this is not just a platform
there's you know there's dozens of
people with PhDs in psychology you know
why smarter than you know than the
average person in terms of how they
understand human behavior how they
understand themselves oh you know
ensuring that you spend as much time as
possible on these platforms and you
think that there's anything
that can be done or what what what's
gonna be the impact first of all of this
if you project it into the future and is
there anything we can do as a society
maybe legislatively to start to curb
some of these things yeah I mean III
think it will I think we're already
beginning to see so sort of gaming
addictions already accepted in places
like Japan not not yet in the in the
States but I think it's happening we
know that we know that again even from a
psychological point of view you know
self-harm which we we tend to see quite
a lot of it especially with sort of
adolescents and adults we're beginning
to see that in the digital form so
digital self-harm where young people are
bullying themselves online anonymously
now this is a new thing and well yeah
you've got to tell us more about so
there's been cases where young people
have been horrifically bullied online
and as we know there's been you know
horrific cases where they've taken their
own lives or attempted to and what we
find now is in some cases certainly
certainly not all but in some cases
these young people will actually be in
such a low place that they create
another profile and they bully
themselves they call themselves stupid
or ugly or horrible and the premise we
believe because this is very new this is
not something we know you know we don't
have much data on but we believe it's
the same thing it's about it's about
showing the pain showing the the pain I
feel inside and externalizing it and
being able to deal with it so you know
all of these things are affecting us and
this is just mental health cognitive
health is being affected as well we know
that Millennials now there's some
studies to attest to the fact that
Millennials have worse memories than
seniors and we know we know that because
when you consolidate a memory if you
keep being interrupted you're never
gonna consolidate that memory so try and
remember something when I keep clean you
keep hearing buzzing or pinyon you're
having to re answer that email there's a
reason for this sleep disorders huge
problem they're on the rise why because
this blue light that we're constantly on
affects us sleeps really important we
believe that sleep is one of the factors
that is implicated in depression so
there's so much going on and and I think
kind of our tech has outpaced our social
evolution our physiological evolution
and we're trying to play catch-up if you
asked the question already why am I here
and I suppose one of the reasons I'm
here is I gave a TED talk back in about
2009 I think so that's nine years ago
and I simply made the Eurostar gag
fantastic fantastic little story okay a
couple of days beforehand the point was
that they were spending six billion
pounds building high-speed rail tracks
between some pancreas and the chem coast
to reduce the overall journey time
between London and Paris London and
Brussels as well by about 25 minutes
okay now my snarky little suggestion was
look what is a bit weird is we're
spending six billion on these rail
tracks and the trains this was true
until two years ago okay so the trains
don't have Wi-Fi now I don't know our
southeastern trains which you share with
me from Tunbridge Wells they're now
installing Wi-Fi they are by actually
getting half the time I'm actually
annoyed my train arrives Severn Bridge
to get here today I stayed on until
Charing Cross because I was in the
middle of something if you put Wi-Fi on
something essentially time loses its
meaning okay but also you're perfectly
productive or entertained so actually
you know the time doesn't matter nearly
as much so you can reduce what you might
call perceptual journey time not at the
cost of six billion which is what it
costs to reduce actual journey time you
can reduce it at a cost of what's
promptly five million six million which
is literally no point one percent of the
cost I said look if you want to be more
perverse I just got sillier I said you
know if you really want to improve the
Eurostar you had a budget of six billion
you'd hire all the world's top male and
female supermodels getting to walk up
and down the train handing out free shut
it the truce to all the passengers
you saved five billion pounds could cost
you about a billion pounds to do that
and people will ask for the trains to be
slowed down totally that is what you
might call the advertising cousin Joe
comedic technique which is the reframing
joke yes which is you tell something you
know there you know the most boring
thing is you know you know that joke
which seems completely innocent until
you flip the context by saying that you
know I you know I was masturbating the
other day blah blah blah and then
something introduced about that it was
in Sainsbury's basically what is there
is that it's exactly the same thing
which is that human decision-making is
quite often and human perception is
badly constrained by conceptual frame
for what you might call a mind trap and
comedy is one of the ways in which you
can liberate yourself from this so I'll
give you a little real-world story which
is you may remember it's one of my
favorite sketches even though as I said
it makes no sense it's a Rowan Atkinson
sketch from normal o'clock news where he
goes into a bathroom showroom and they
have various bottle showers baths etc in
which he can actually design his own
bathroom and he just decides he's gonna
have a bathroom with seven timer
gorgeous right anybody who's seen it
will still remember it 35 years later
someone comes to me with a problem which
is the fireman in certain American
cities when they're not fighting fires
which actually is most of the time
because smoke detection equipment and so
on and vastly less flammable fabrics
have reduced the incidence of of
domestic fires quite super significantly
so they go around typically to poorer
areas in the u.s. to housing projects
and they try and install smoke detectors
for free
noble worthwhile think to now one of the
things they can never get their head
around I can't understand it either
entirely is that they can get nearly
everybody and they writ on the door and
say fireman here we're just here install
a smoke detector you basically you get
them to install one but they really balk
at two or three and the typical
apartment really needs three the strange
thing is that's like saying no I don't
want one in my child's bedroom it's a
really weird thing to say but for some
reason people just draw the line at what
maybe two when three is necessary okay
now I used that same Caterpie flask
you know bizarre approach to suggest the
solution which is very simple thing in
behavioral science is just reacting I
said it partly was okay i partly
suggested absolutely outrageous things
which which would never be legal or
acceptable which is to actually outrage
people by saying you know well actually
if you're korean you'd be entitled to
three but since you're african-american
you only get two so you absolutely cause
some sort of outrage hmm now and
Competitiveness comparison that a friend
of mine whose wife was Chinese he was
invited to visit South Africa and she
they didn't go but she wasn't allowed to
share the same hotel with him and they
rang up and said his young wife Chinese
or Japanese
she said she's Singaporean Chinese uh
unfortunately or Jill needs ten
different Oh Jo she wasn't all about
saying different hotel for our husband
the idea that had she been Japanese it
would have been okay drove her
practically yes yes we forget this fact
actually and one of the problems the
British left they assumed complete
harmony among all external
ethnic groups well the Chinese Japanese
rivalries and with some reason in some
cases yes yes still pretty intense okay
so one of the things one of the reasons
and this is why free speech and
advertising by the way of free speech in
comedy are both really really
things to fight for now no one is
suggesting for a second I'm never gonna
do that okay
but it just dropped me as a really
interesting idea or how to get people to
accept free is to suggest that they
weren't actually one of the ideas about
how you get younger children to eat
insects is to have a part of notice you
say well unfortunately because you're
under 16 you won't be allowed to eat you
know basically you know the magazine the
magazine just 17 had an average
readership age of about 13 you know you
know so so actually telling people that
you're not eligible for something drives
them practically and say that's
interesting but then the reason the free
speech thing is important is because
there is a whole area of ideas which
belong in an ad agency which I would
describe as you'd get promoted for
making the suggestion and fired for
enacting it that I suggest is an example
of that okay if you actually had the
idea I'd be impressed by your ingenuity
if you actually executed it I'd be
horrified by your lack of judgment say
that thing is really really important
because one speech is experimental
action so applying the same criteria to
speech as you do to physical actions is
ridiculous because one of the reasons
we've evolved humour and speech is it's
nature's flight simulator it's where we
try things out without actually doing
them and probably the road of stories a
whole bunch of things exist as a kind of
simulation but the second thing is
sometimes in advertising in in problem
solving of any kind you kind of have to
climb Mount silly to get to the bright
sunlit uplands block below beyond and
what I eventually suggested borrowing
from that Rowan Atkinson sketch for the
smoke to take thing is I said turn up
with six that's six is ridiculous number
and if you say to the people well you
know we normally bring six smoke
detectors to our home but I think here
you can make do with three or four
you'll probably get them to install for
three or four three in fact because one
now seems weirdly on the low side once
you've acted them at six one the seems
like well no I don't have one
that's insanity right and so having the
ability to say and think and I would
argue the principle value of an ad
agency isn't actually the production of
advertising or communication
it's the existence of a culture where
the plant company's interests at heart
but with a culture in which it is
possible to say ridiculous things and
still get promoted that's one of most
important things that that agency can
have is the ability to say something
totally ridiculous which in say the
civil service will be career suicide or
in politics would probably be career
suicide
unless you you know unless you're a
Boris Johnson you managed to kind of be
which case Jesus I mean I don't like
what he says but at least at least I
believe in when he says it yeah I think
a lot of people feel that one of the
reasons he probably you know where you
are with a good play which is that the
elite priestly caste has become
basically weird it's become fixated with
a very very narrow world view which is
instilled in all those kind of religious
ceremonies that take place in divorce or
business schools or whatever which are
all inculcating exactly the same creed
okay by the way conservative I'm not
making this as a kind of weird left-wing
point but I don't think anybody can
reasonably say that there's a complete
lack of imagination and weirdness in
politics and business which is that it's
become obsessed with an incredibly
narrow way of defining worldly progress
and success mostly around efficiency and
cost reduction which is not really very
well aligned with what people really
care about
[Music]
you and I met two years ago at kill
cannot mix in Ireland doing comedy and
we were chatting in the bar after one of
the shows that we were on and you were
telling me about this new thing in China
where they're going to have the system
where they're gonna track everybody's
behavior and all this stuff and I'll be
honestly pepper I really like you
but I was sitting there listening to you
going she's a little bit crazy little
bit crazy maybe she's lost a lot of weed
when she was yes yes so interesting yeah
I was sitting there and then a year
later boom it's happened it's real and
that's what you were talking to us about
last time you were on the show what the
hell is going on and what what's to come
because now I believe you thank you okay
so let's just quickly go through what is
already real right if you J walk in not
all of China they've only rolled it out
in one city but they're gonna roll it
out nationally a few jaywalk it clocks
that you've done it because the cameras
are ubiquitous now so the facial
recognition is incredibly strong they
have the most valuable artificial
intelligence startup in the world in
fact the most valuable startup in the
world called cents time and it can
recognize an individual out of a crowd
of 10,000 and it can recognize your
emotional state at any given time so it
clocks its you and particularly you next
thing you know you picked your mobile
phone up and the fine for having
jaywalked is already in your text
messages if not already deducted from
your bank account and your name and or
your government number is already
broadcast on the OLED screen that's
above the intersection the nearest
intersection so you've now been
broadcast to everyone nearby that you
are bad and you just violated the law
now this is important because what it
does is affects your effectively
personal uber score they're the social
credit system is based on the idea that
you're given a score and which reflects
your social compliance so if you google
stuff that they don't want you looking
at your score goes down if your brother
or your sister
does it your score goes down right
because Mao always said the the best
eyes and Watchers are it's not the
government it's to get a better report
on each other and this is a kind of us I
mean the Stasi would love the system but
it's bigger than that within the last
few weeks it's been announced that when
you tap swipe and pinch on your mobile
device it's a better indicator of who
you are than your thumbprint so now even
if you're using someone else's phone
they know it's you triangulate that with
the way you walk it turns out your
walking gait is also a better indicator
of who you are then your thumbprint so
what they're doing is taking all these
things and triangulating think about it
as previously independent silos of data
now they triangulate using artificial
intelligence to pull it all together but
it goes even deeper than that
and recently they arrested someone at a
rock concert of like 60,000 people
because again the face went by one
camera banging at clock's this is person
is wanted and they went to the person's
seat come you know the debit card
yep the ticket that they're arrested I
think they now have 11 million people
who are you can buy a train ticket or a
plane ticket but you can't board it they
won't permit you so effectively you
wherever you are no so they're putting
you into digital digital prisons so I
think one of the spouses of one of the
dissenters she's like blocked into a
very small few block area around her
house and anytime she tries to move
beyond it the officials are alerted and
a police will be right there
so she's literally stuck in it in a
digital prison this is basically what
the technology permits and it rewards
you if you do things that are supportive
of what government said shouldn't and it
basically penalizes you if you don't
we're doing the same thing in the West
it's just it's not government that's
doing it we have private entities that
do it we have Facebook that desert we
have Amazon that doesn't we have uber
that does it and I don't know if you saw
but there's been an announced
there's been a deal between it seems
Google and MasterCard so now if I go to
you know I don't know a department store
and I buy this color lipstick Google's
gonna know and now they know what
they're gonna advertise to me so I'm
concerned about this and I write a lot
about this in my book because imagine
what we've got it's a world where you
were emitting data points about yourself
all the time without even knowing it
because you've turned all the fitness
apps off on your phone but the fact is
the way you walk is revealing a lot
about you including by the way your your
cardiac condition a lot about your
health is revealed by how you walk
so this multiplicity of data points that
you're throwing off but you don't know
who gets to see it but whoever does get
to see it they know more about you than
you know about yourself and by the way
it's a two-way thing if I'm a chief
executive and I go on let's say this
program and I start talking about my
company and I'm lying
this same facial recognition technology
can identify your micro facial movements
and they know that you're lying and they
can set the algorithms just short the
stock of your company as you're talking
on say CNBC's Squawk Box so think of it
as almost like a crystal ball of data
points and on the one side it will let
us conjure forth answers that will do
things like solve cancer literally we
will solve extraordinarily difficult
problems by having all this data but it
also changes the balance of power
between companies and customers because
companies will have so much information
that I've argued you know we used to
have insider trading laws we may need
insider trading laws that if I am
MasterCard now or Google my knowledge of
you is so great forget Cambridge
analytic ah they only had five thousand
data points on 81 million people and
that was enough to begin to influence
your political position I could sell you
way more than a political position if I
have more than that I can tell you a
refrigerator I can tell you anything I
want so I think human beings are very
vulnerable to this kind of power being
exercised and similarly what kind of
world do we have if people don't know
how
they appear and this there should we
have a right to know how do we look with
that data
slice looking at us at any given time so
in the book I've tried to lay this out
because we have a lot of leaders who are
making decisions about the landscape of
our future who don't understand what I'm
saying
and so they're they're literally missing
a profound shift in humanity well this
is the future I mean this is now it's
not even the future this is nothing I'm
not telling you is for the future
it is already existing right now
jockeying aside but then that literally
means if you will be interactive every
single second of every day if they're
reading what you were doing if they can
manipulate you is that the end of free
will eventually this is the this we're
so what's really intrigued to me is when
I was in college I studied political
philosophy and everyone went oh my god
you will never get a job
I mean you are permanently out of point
if you stay now we get to this and I'm
like these are questions of political
philosophy that's exactly what this is
this is about the balance of power
between states and citizens companies
and customers between citizens it's
about the the invasion of persons free
will absolutely these are all core
questions now they're not tangential
anymore and I and the more we develop
artificial intelligence the greater than
abhi for example
I know a guy who's building an
extraordinary company it is effectively
gonna place nano chips which are so
small that that they can fit inside the
body they are at the level or they're
below the level of atoms right you're
basically in the you're into the level
of you can see someone's atomic
structure their nuke their DNA their
cellular structure and their organs
because it's just they float around in
your body at the nano level so that
means the good news is
when you get cancer you get proteins in
advance of the cancer which now we don't
detect very well but and and you'll be
able to say you're building up proteins
we see it coming we can hit this thing
and you'll never get cancer but the bad
news is you're omitting information
about what is physically happening to
you to whoever has access to that data
again the good news is that will create
a kind of he calls it a cure chain the
guy who founded it see Papermaster like
block chain it's a cure chain we'll be
able to cure many obscure diseases that
only a few people have that right now
are worth fixing but with that you can
fix it easily but talk about privacy I
mean the health care companies will know
more about your health and you will ever
know about your own health so yes these
are really profound philosophical
questions well here's the thing is it's
not just health as well because we had
an evolutionary psychologist on the show
a few weeks back I don't know if you
caught that episode
Diana Fleischman and one of the things
she was talking about is genetic studies
the study of genetics is now coming to a
point where we can pretty confidently
say that there's a very strong genetic
component to behavior yes right so if
you can analyze people at that level and
their DNA and their genetics you're not
just gonna be able to tell what disease
they might develop or whatever you're
gonna be able to tell what their
personality type is to some extent what
their choices are gonna be what their
political leanings are gonna be I think
you guys are really missing you know
remember Minority Report and that idea
of precut pre-crime yeah dad is already
real in China they're already using the
artificial intelligence in conjunction
with this extraordinary data sweep and
they are determining which people look
more inclined to cut corners than others
and then to start crowling them into a
corner and putting pressure to behave
better that's today that's not maybe
some day we already see this in motion
so there's again this is a huge
philosophical question as this question
of prejudging precognition premeditation
where do we draw these lines subscribe
to us on YouTube give us a rating on
iTunes follow us everywhere you can we
are on Twitter on Instagram on Facebook
all these terrible social media
platforms that please keep using them
anything else Francis yeah don't smoke
weed whilst you're watching this and if
you've enjoyed it we'll see you in a
week's time with another brilliant
episode thank you very much goodbye